[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre au début du mois
s'est tenu le procès de deux avocats
poursuivi pour avoir communiqué lors
d'un procès des pièces qui ont été
ultérieurement jugées comme étant des
faux confectionnés par leurs clients
bien qu'il n'ait pas eu conscience du
caractère frauduleux de ces pièces ce
que leur reconnaît d'ailleurs
l'accusation il aurait reproché d'avoir
prêté leur concours à la manipulation en
ne voulant pas voir ces accusations sont
extrêmement graves et les peines
requises contre ces deux avocats aussi
de l'emprisonnement ferme et une
interdiction d'exercer pendant cinq
années monsieur le ministre je ne doute
pas une seconde que si cette actualité
était intervenue il y a quelques années
lorsque vous portiez encore la robe vous
seriez insurgés offusqué contre cette
atteinte inadmissible au droit de la
défense et contre notre profession
nous
vous aurez que les avocats n'ont pas à
leur disposition
les instructions
par client
nous vous aurions entendu tonique ces
deux confrères n'ont violé aucune règle
déontologique ni aucune règle légale et
nous vous aurions entendu interpellé le
ministre de la Justice en lui rappelant
que le chemin qui se dessine c'est celui
de la mise à mort programmée des droits
de la défense et que désormais les
avocats ne pourront plus que défendre
des innocents et encore s'il démontre
préalable la véracité de leur pièce nous
vous aurions entendu conclure qu'un
avocat dans un procès c'est un cuisinier
dans un repas et qu'il fait avec les
aliments qu'on lui apporte alors
serez-vous le ministre qui aura scellé
le destin des droits de la défense où
êtes-vous encore cette ardent défenseur
des libertés fondamentales qui aura le
courage de réformer enfin le droit
positif en créant l'immunité de la robe
pour ceux de vos anciens confrères qui
font ce que vous avez fait durant des
décennies défendre des coupables
innocents et d'innocents coupables
je vous remercie